[Music]
new york had the highest death rate in
the world how could we possibly be
jumping up and down and saying
oh governor cuomo did a great job he had
the worst death rate in the world
no you misconstrued that senator and
you've done that
repetitively in the past if we're not
spreading the infection
isn't it just theater no it's not a
vaccine and you're wearing two masks
isn't that theater no that's not here we
go again with the theater
dr fauci do you still support funding of
the
nih funding of the lab in wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entitled entirely
and completely incorrect i don't favor
gain of function research in chinese
naturally that are not correct
oh man the sparks fly when dr
fauci is interrogated let's say
by kentucky senator rand paul a member
of the senate
education health and labor pensions
committee
and uh the senator joins us right now
good morning to you senator
good morning morning well you're a
doctor so you've got special doctor
questions of the doctor he does not
particularly like it
he was asked this morning over on
another channel
about the give and take between the two
of you he had this to say
can i just ask about you and rand paul
does your body tense up every time
in my body you know what i mean yeah
you know gail i i just don't want to get
into that tit
i just don't understand what the problem
is with him but
you know well i'm just going to do my
job and he could do what he wants to do
and we'll see what happens
well senator he says he's just going to
do his job
but that seems to be what you've got a
problem with how he's doing his job
well if he was being interviewed by a
journalist they would have asked
did the nih did your specific division
of the nih give money to the wuhan lab
that's incontrovertibly true what he's
arguing is he's parsing his words
he knows his group gave money but he's
saying oh it wasn't for
juicing up these super viruses we gave
it for other research
it's sort of like the planned parenthood
argument yes we give taxpayer money to
planned parenthood but it's not for
abortion
dr fauci's arguing yeah we gave it to
you know the nih and my group
specifically gave it to the wuhan lab
but they weren't supposed to be juicing
up money is fungible as you say on
capitol hill
but it's even worse than that the doctor
she the bat scientist that's the most
famous one from the wuhan institute
when she published her papers which
scientists across the board are saying
are gain of function
they were juicing up viruses she gave
credit to dr fauci she said the funding
came from
we have this in black and white from a
peer-reviewed journal
she said the funding came from dr
falchi's
national institute aid niaid this is dr
fauci's baby for 40 years
she lists him in the credits he can't
escape this
he did the funding and my other question
is china's a rich country they're
kicking our butt
in so many places why would we be giving
them money for their research
can't they spend their own money on
their own research senator paul dr fauci
calls your exchange a tit for tat and he
said he doesn't know what your problem
is
that's because he's been placed on a
pedestal and no one thinks it's
appropriate to question him
no one it seems except for you and a few
others have you received the answers
that you want we saw in that clip you're
asking them about using new york as a
model
why you should be masked when you when
you have already received the vaccine
and importantly what you're talking
about this morning the origins
of the coronavirus he said to you
directly that's not true
regarding his supportive gain of
function when we know there's an
editorial going back to 2011
that he has supported gain of function
research have you received the answers
you're looking for senator
no but we've sent inquiries there's been
freedom of information as well as
increase from house oversight
when it was under republicans and now
from our office ron johnson others
we're asking specifically for some nih
papers and the conclusions
because in those conclusions we believe
it will be unequivocal
from a group of scientists that they
will conclude that yes the wuhan
institute was making these super viruses
now they're still going to argue they
didn't fund it but this is a really
important argument it's not a partisan
argument
so when dr fauci goes on these other
channels and they laugh it up and yuck
it up
but they never ask him did you fund the
institute see he's trying to evade that
he funded it at all
i asked him the general question i
didn't ask him whether he funded gain of
function
i said did the nih fund the wuhan lab
and he he danced around it and answered
a different question
but there is no question at all that the
nih funded this lab
whether it was gain of function there's
many scientists dr e bright
dr baltimore many scientists out there
there were 200
scientists in the cambridge working
group that are worried about creating
these super viruses in the lab
and the possibility that they could get
out this isn't just me
it's not partisan politics shouldn't be
partisan at all we
should we should want to protect the
public in case another virus like this
could escape
this is so crazy though because if this
happened
because of the nih funding and that came
from dr fauci
and then this spreads into a global
pandemic and now he's in charge
of the response in the united states the
irony of that what do you make
of that well it's eve it's even worse
than you make out the person they
appointed to investigate the lab
from the who perspective is the guy who
gave the money
so nih gave the money to a group called
eco health
the head of eco health a guy named
dasank they
got him to investigate whether wuhan was
doing anything inappropriate in their
lab
but if they were wouldn't he then be
culpable so doesn't he have a
self-interest in
smoothing things over i'm not saying he
did cover things up but you wouldn't
appoint
someone who's in the line of supply
chain of giving the money to them
because ultimately here's the rub i
don't know whether it came to the lab
nobody knows whether it came from the
lab
but who would be cultivable dr fauci
could be culpable for the entire
pandemic
so could dr sazank dasank and so could
dr
xi i'm not saying that happened i don't
know
but you wouldn't put the people who gave
the money to the wuhan lab in charge of
the investigation
that looks like a cover-up no kidding
and it's curious that it seems like the
only people
asking about the origin of the
coronavirus which has killed
tens of thousands of americans all seem
to be republicans which is
odd it shouldn't be that way absolutely
there should be bipartisan concern
there's 11 labs
in the united states that are cooking up
and creating super viruses
that's that's worrisome just the term
super viruses is pretty scary
senator doctor thank you very much for
joining us thank you